except everyone welcome to another HD
unboxing video and yes I know there's
been a lot of unboxing videos in the
last few videos and the software trust
me is still coming but this is get
another unboxing video for a company
called jello schemes and I'll throw up
their website right now that they kindly
sent out a gelaskin for a 17 inch laptop
that I can show you guys how to install
how to use do a full review video on it
so I hear you i'm just going to shift
this contest to the bottom so i can open
it up here at the top mini i don't want
to yeah i don't want to cut anything in
the package maybe I should uh oh here we
go we got a little opening no not quite
an opening but we can open it through
this part so here we go yes you work so
um this is again like I said it's going
to sit a cemetery flap hop and just do a
gelaskins r or skincare laptop are if
didn't already know it's just something
that you can have on your laptop so you
can know it's yours personally like I
say you go to LAN party and there's a
lot of people's laptops there well which
laptop is yours well mine is the one
with the yellow skin on I'm not just the
black HP so this one right here first
says to check out the gallery at
gelaskins and again their link will be
in the description so I more gelaskins
Joe skins they also make iPod skins and
stuff like that etc this is an enjoyable
skins a little pad there I guess not a
mouse pad but maybe I coaster Wolfie and
let's all just going to put this off
camera here since this was just
basically a gelaskins unboxing and here
is the skin itself now I know if you've
ever seen this drawing before by MC
Escher I can even fit in the picture
there yes I will have that on the back
of my laptop at the top it says
customize your laptop with artist
designed removable skins so yeah let's
just basically see first of all anything
else in the box no nothing else is empty
so that goes off to the side so yeah I'm
not only going to show you guys I'm
send it to the end of this video but I'm
kind of a wide package of click on the
back to see what it says so it's easy on
Easy Off it is backed by adhesive
technology from 3n when we all know that
the tape making company and basically
you can take this off of your laptop at
any time put it back on since what five
laptop you have and gives a little size
shirt I have a 17 inch laptop here so
yeah I'm going to show you guys actually
the installation of the the gelaskin on
my laptop and see exactly how it looks
how good it looks see how it's 50 HP 17
inch for ice cream so yeah that gives
you easy to apply instructions you can
read that it says to clean your laptop
for soil get away all the oil and dirt
so you don't get them any air bubbles
peel the jello skin off slide it onto
your laptop make sure it's centered and
then press firmly to work to the edges
to get away all the air bubbles so um
thanks for watching in boxing video I
will definitely do something like an
installation video to get you guys
basically more information on how this
how this works maybe you wanted to go
check out their website hit one for your
ipod or something so just so you know
it's kind of like a music skin basically
something you might want to get to pimp
out your ipod customize it but thanks
for watching this unboxing video from
mkbhd hope you like it and go check out
the website and maybe you want to check
one of these out so stay tuned for the
installation and the for review video
guys thief